it's great to welcome to the program
today Anna Merlin who is a senior
reporter at Geo Media Group and author
of the new book Republic of Lies and are
so great to talk to you today thanks for
having me
so we spoke I guess now it was a couple
of weeks ago with Nancy rosenbloom from
Harvard University about the rise in
conspiracism sort of separate from
specific conspiracy theories in a sense
and the the sort of underlying societal
issues that come with that etc I want to
talk with you a little bit about the way
in which the theories themselves have
kind of evolved over time and then maybe
we can dig into the impact of that I
mean give us a general sense like where
did conspiracy theories start how have
they changed in the last hundred years
in the last five years mm-hmm
well conspiracy theories have always
been a part of society and they've
especially always been a part of
American society from the outset what we
know is that up until World War two most
ordinary people's conspiracy theories
were about outside groups what they
perceived as outside groups whether that
was communists masons Jews you know some
kind of paranoia about these outside
groups seizing control and then after
World War one is the federal government
got bigger most ordinary people's
conspiracy theories started to center
around the government itself and who was
really in charge and what the government
was really doing um I would say that in
the last five years the main change that
we've seen is the number of people who
are trying to make money off of some
type of conspiracism what I and other
people refer to as conspiracy
entrepreneurs people who see some kind
of Avenue for fame or success through
spreading what some folks would consider
to be conspiratorial ideas are there
that's super interesting actually are
there particular types or specific
conspiracy theories that are
particularly profitable and if so why I
wouldn't say so no I mean what we know
is that most people tend to feel more
comfortable with conspiracy theories
that line up with where they are
politically and socially already so you
know conspiracy theories garner support
from people on the right if they are
right leaning the same with on the Left
what
I do see however is that most people
can't make money as conspiracy
entrepreneurs solely from just going on
YouTube are having a periscope they're
really successful ones are people like
Alex Jones who also sell a product Alex
Jones you know I think most people know
by now most of the money that he makes
is from sales of supplements and other
products that are sort of nominally
health oriented yeah there are I mean a
lot of conspiracy theories have nothing
to do with religion per se but it's
interesting that one of the ways that
some of these religious media outlets
are also monetizing is by using sort of
I don't know whether the conspiracy
theory is the right term but but sort of
apocalyptic fears and rapture sort of
imagery and that type of thing also to
be selling a product and it seems that
that is a sort of integral part of the
Entrepreneurship component yeah it's
very common and you'll see a lot of
overlap among those groups there is a
big sort of apocalyptic especially
Christian element and a lot of American
right-wing conspiracy culture but I mean
fundamentally one of the core aspects of
conspiracism is this idea that some
massive consequential damaging change is
right around the corner and that if
action is not taken right now something
terrible would have will happen which is
of course a really profitable way to
sell all kinds of things is by creating
the sense of urgency and fear and panic
can you give an example of I mean I
don't know no that I necessarily want to
brand all conspiracy theories as either
sort of a real world dangerous or real
world harmless it seems there's probably
some kind of spectrum but at least to
kind of get into that discussion can you
give an example of a prevalent
conspiracy theory that does not seem to
connect to sort of like real-world
danger either for the believers in it or
for others bystanders as we might call
them and then on the other side one that
does have significant real-world
consequences mmm like you say it's
really really hard to classify things
that way because a lot of people have
sort of overlapping conspiratorial
beliefs you know a lot of times people
will antal enter through one subculture
and end up elsewhere and it's really
hard to tell who is going to take real
damaging actions I mean for instance
Flat Earth is the subculture that is
very small but it is growing we know
there are more flat earthers than there
were a few years ago and on its surface
that one is pretty silly but it is
harmless more or less you know it's a
little bit alarming but it is harmless
however I and other people who cover
this have noted that there is a lot of
Cola cost denial in those worlds that
something about flat earther ism tends
to lead to a kind of question everything
mentality that goes into some really
weird and potentially dark places and of
course once you get into Holocaust
denial you are more susceptible to white
nationalist ideas right um so it can be
really hard to say but yeah on its face
Flat Earth is probably not a huge cause
for concern I would say things like
pizza gate and cue and I on the other
hand have been mostly harmless but
obviously there have been some pretty
sizable exceptions to that mainly Edgar
Welch who went to comet ping-pong in DC
the supposed sight of this Democrat run
child sex slave ring with a gun you know
intent on saving children and so I would
say that the the subcultures that make
me the most nervous are obviously the
ones that are tight with tied with white
nationalism and extremism as well as the
ones that brand their enemies as child
abusers because when you are talking
about child abuse when you were accusing
someone of being a pedophile or someone
who hurts children um it justifies any
kind of action against them there is
almost nothing that isn't justified to
stop that kind of behavior and so it
sets up this very apocalyptic
potentially violent rhetoric that does
make me a little bit nervous here's what
I don't understand about the sort of
transfer from one conspiracy theory to
belief in another so you mentioned the
idea of you get in through Flat Earth
and then all of a sudden you end up with
like Holocaust denial why do we not seem
to see and if it exists I would love to
hear about it you don't see people who
for example enter via Flat Earth and
then come to the realization that huge
corporations that been
that from cheap immigrant labor love the
idea that there is this sort of argument
or debate between low and middle income
people and immigrants over who is
actually responsible for keeping wages
low and stealing jobs that's a real
thing where we have these huge
corporations benefitting by sort of
fomenting that battle right you don't
really see the traditional conspiracy
theorists ever end up with that one
which happens to be true they end up
with something more cartoonish like
Holocaust denial why is that the path
and not the one that I mentioned I mean
it could be that some individual
conspiracy consumers do come to more or
less the place that you're talking about
you know people who for instance entered
through something like 9/11 truther ISM
from the documentary loose change you
know which was pretty influential for a
bunch of people in that world not all of
those people became hardcore 9/11
truthers some of them came to believe
that there was yeah as you say just a
political and social reason why those
why those conspiracy theories spread I
think really I would say that we don't
see people sort of loudly and publicly
leaving conspiracy communities for a
more reality based version of the world
because it the algorithms that spread
conspiracy theories don't really reward
those kinds of claims or proclamations
somebody who is a really really big
conspiracy youtuber just sort of doesn't
have any particular motivation to come
out and say that they were wrong and
they've actually come to a different and
more grounded view of the world can you
quantify in any way the effect that the
Trump president presidency has had on
belief in conspiracy theories and
conspiratorial thinking so we know that
conspiracy theories wax and wane in
America depending on sort of times of
social upheaval times of social and
people's social unrest when we're
questioning who we are as people we tend
to see a rise in conspiracism and
typically whatever political party is
out of power is more prone to conspiracy
theorizing so we see a little bit more
of it on the left and we did during the
Obama years what is really unique about
the term presidency of course is that he
himself uses conspiracy theories
spread them and seems to see them as a
way to solidify his base solidify
support for him and to try to identify a
common enemy to encourage his supporters
to be mad at you know instead of him a
scapegoat which is something that we see
a lot in more authoritarian countries
it's unusual but not unheard of for a
u.s. president and it really sort of
raises the stakes of what conspiracy
theories mean you know if Trump wakes up
tomorrow and decides to start tweeting
that vaccines cause autism or you know
that Q really not really done by the way
which he's previously done yes he
previously did that before he was
president and has not talked about it
too much since he's become president
which is a very good thing but yeah if
he wakes up and decides to start
promoting a more virulent conspiracy
theory from the Oval Office that will
have huge effects obviously you
mentioned that it's it's unusual but not
without precedent to see a president
pushing stuff like this what are other
examples of presidents I mean Nixon is
obviously the most obvious example of a
conspiracy theorist president he was
someone who believed you know that there
was a communist plot against him that
was actually orchestrated by Jews um
when Andrew Jackson someone tried to
assassinate Andrew Jackson and he came
to believe that it was functionally the
deep state
you know functionally that there was
some kind of plot within government to
assassinate him instead of a lone gunman
so we see it like here and there
throughout American history um something
that is really sort of unusual about
Trump is that we can see it in real time
and we can see it via social media how
he's attempting to sort of use these
theories for his own gain yeah that's
been a definite change in terms of the
environment around the president for
sure absolutely fascinating stuff we've
been speaking with an emergen who is a
senior reporter at Geo Media Group also
author of the new book Republic of Lies
which I highly encourage you to check
out Anna thank you so much for talking
to me today thank you for having me I
appreciate it